il était passé sous les radars ce
rapport 89 pages qui analyse les
conséquences de l'application du pacte
vert européen vous vous souvenez le
green deal est présenté en 2019
plusieurs stratégies pour verdir le
continent y compris son agriculture
alors on ne va pas rentrer dans les
détails retenez seulement qu'il s'agit
de réduire les émissions de co2
notamment en diminuant lusage d'engrais
de pesticides en sollicitant moins de
surfaces agraires etc etc et bien si
l'on en croit ce document ces stratégies
menace clairement la production agricole
européenne à commencer par les céréales
-15% en cause la baisse des surfaces
cultivées et des rendements affecté par
un moindre emploi des engrais pesticides
idem du côté des oléagineux noix
pistaches amandes et c'est moins 15% là
aussi - 13 % pour les fruits et légumes
et la production baissent aussi du côté
des éleveurs - 10 % pour les produits
laitiers -17 5% pour la viande bovine et
environ -15% pour le port et les
volailles en clair l'europe va produire
moins de nourriture on va créer des
dépendances là où il n'y en avait pas et
affaiblir nos points forts et tout cela
à un moment où le giec explique qu'un
des premiers risques du changement
climatique c'est la rupture des chaînes
alimentaires absurde d'autant que ce
rapport n'est pas le premier du genre en
novembre dernier une étude du
département américain de l'agriculture
parvenait aux mêmes conclusions et si
l'on en croit les chiffres le green deal
agricole européen mènerait à une chute
de la production de l'union européenne
de 12 % des exportations de 20 % et des
dépenses en nourriture qui augmenterait
de près de 130 euros par an et par
personne et ça c'est uniquement si lieu
est la seule à appliquer ces règles dans
un monde où le pacte vert européen
deviendrait la norme ce sont 185
millions de personnes qui seraient jetés
dans l'insécurité alimentaire avec une
perte de pib mondial de près de 1000
milliards d'euros soit à peu près
l'équivalent du pib du mexique alors
tous ces chiffres ne signifient pas
qu'il faille renoncer à verdir notre
agriculture et préserver la biodiversité
ils veulent plutôt dire qu'avec près de
8 milliards d'humains sur terre la
transition écologique ne se fera pas
sans douleur